Bonjour, on se retrouve aujoud’hui pour
une vidéo portrait, format assez rare sur
Passé sauvage pour le souligner, d’une
personnalité qui a marqué l’anthropologie du XXème
Margaret Mead
Cet épisode est aussi le dernier de la saison
Je n'ai pas prévu de publier cet été donc on se retrouve en septembre !
Petite parenthèse, j'ai un code promo à vous proposer
Un code promo pour NordVPN qui vous offre 70% de réduction sur les abonnements
C'est un code affilié c'est-à-dire que je touche une comission pour chaque abonnement souscrit
Toutes les infos sont dans la barre dédiée sous la vidéo
Anthropologue américaine, Margaret Mead réalise
de longs séjours d’étude en Océanie entre
1920 et 1940. Elle y développe une pensée
originale, analysant notamment l’adolescence
et le genre. Ses sujets d’étude tout comme
ses divorces à répétition ou encore ses
prises de position sur la bisexualité choquent
l’Amérique puritaine de l’entre-deux-guerres.
Aventurière intrépide devenue icône féministe,
pionnière des études de genre ayant subi
une avalanche de critiques, on revient dans
cette vidéo sur la vie et l’œuvre de Margaret Mead.
Née à Philadelphie en 1901 d’un père
professeur d’économie à l’université
et d’une mère diplômée de sociologie,
Mead est familiarisée dès l’enfance avec
les sciences sociales. Elle rentre à l’université
de Columbia à vingt ans en 1921 pour étudier
la psychologie et l’anthropologie. Là-bas,
elle est formée par Franz Boas et son assistante
Ruth Benedict.
Obsédée par l’idée d’être
utile et de sauvegarder des cultures exotiques
en train de disparaître, elle entre en anthropologie
comme on entre en religion, prête à se rendre
à l’autre bout du monde pour accomplir
sa mission.
A peine mariée avec Luther Cressman, un pasteur
protestant qui étudie la sociologie, elle
part seule aux Samoa en 1925. Elle s’installe
au dispensaire de l’île de Tau, à l’est
de l’archipel, et devient rapidement le
centre d’attention des jeunes filles de
l’île qui passent toutes leurs journées
avec elle. En neuf mois, Mead récolte ainsi
les plus infimes et intimes détails de la
vie de ces adolescentes. C’est à partir
de leurs témoignages qu’elle construit
son étude et publie à son retour Adolescence
à Samoa, en 1927.
L’objectif de son livre est de comparer
l’adolescence aux Samoa et aux Etats-Unis.
Finalement, elle conclut que « L’adolescence
aux Samoa n’est donc en aucune façon une
période de crise et de tension, mais bien
au contraire une évolution calme vers la
maturité. » Cette position vient fortement
nuancer les croyances de l’époque sur l’adolescence
comme un moment de crise obligatoire. Ce premier
livre a un certain écho aux Etats-Unis et
Mead est encouragée à poursuivre ses recherches.
Sur le bateau du retour des Samoa, Mead rencontre
un jeune psychologue néo-zélandais, Reo Fortune
Cherchez pas y'a pas plus classe comme nom
Nan mais j'ai cherché : Mike, John...Jérôme
Ça fait pas pareil
Ils se rendent tous les deux en Europe
et passent la traversée à parler avec passion
d’anthropologie et de psychologie. Ils finissent
par débarquer à Marseille, six semaines
plus tard, amoureux. Elle rentre aux Etats-Unis
en 1926 et s’attelle à la rédaction de
son livre. Son terrain l’a toutefois profondément
changée.
Avec son mari, pasteur protestant et sociologue,
Mead avait imaginé vivre dans un presbytère,
avoir « au moins six » enfants et consacrer
sa vie à aider les nécessiteux. Au retour
des Samoa, ce projet semble définitivement
oublié. D’autant que Mead apprend à l’automne
1926 qu’elle a une malformation de l’utérus
qui rend pratiquement impossible d’avoir
des enfants. Elle choisit donc de se séparer
de son mari au printemps 1927 et embarque
pour la Nouvelle-Zélande retrouver Reo Fortune.
Elle choisit volontairement quelqu’un qui,
elle le sait, « ne ferait pas un père idéal
», mais avec qui elle pourra se consacrer
à l’ethnographie de terrain.
Dès qu’ils se retrouvent, Reo et Margaret
se marient et embarquent pour les îles de
l’Amirauté, au nord de la Nouvelle-Guinée.
Là-bas, elle s’intéresse aux mêmes questions
qu’à Samoa, et publie en 1930 Une éducation
en Nouvelle-Guinée, qui enrichit sa théorie.
Très marquée par une approche psychologique,
Mead établit en fait un lien entre les dispositions
psychiques des individus et les cultures qu’elle
observe sur le terrain. Elle décrit en quelque
sorte le tempérament, la personnalité des
cultures, qu’elle entreprend de classer
selon quatre types principaux. Elle utilise
pour cela les points cardinaux[1].
C’est sur son terrain suivant, réalisé
toujours en Nouvelle-Guinée, mais sur la
grande île cette fois-ci entre fin 1931 et
début 1933, qu’elle peut déployer toute
sa théorie. En descendant le fleuve Sépik[2],
elle s’emploie à comparer trois sociétés,
les Arapesh, les Mundugumor et les Chambuli.
Son travail est publié sous le titre Trois
sociétés primitives de Nouvelle-Guinée
(1935, on connaît la publi chez Plon dans les années 60 qui regroupe ces textes)
Dans cet ouvrage elle se concentre sur la question des genres et de la construction des identités.
En mettant en évidence de profondes différences
dans la façon de concevoir le rôle des hommes
et des femmes dans les sociétés qu’elle
a traversées, elle ouvre une perspective
assez taboue dans la société américaine
des années 1930 qui imagine que les femmes
et les hommes ont des rôles dictés par la
nature.
Elle affirme que « la nature humaine est
presque entièrement malléable » et que
le social prime sur le biologique. Autrement
dit, le rôle assigné aux femmes n’a rien
de « naturel ». Cette position ouvre dès
lors la possibilité pour les femmes de revendiquer
une meilleure place dans la société. Et
même si à l’époque, ces arguments sont
déjà avancés par les féministes, Margaret
Mead a l’immense mérite de le prouver par
l’exemple.
Son travail de terrain démontre que les relations
entre hommes et femmes ne sont pas partout
équivalentes à une soumission totale de
ces dernières. Le modèle des Arapesh, chez
lesquels les hommes, tout comme les femmes,
ont « un comportement doux et aimable » s’oppose
aux Mundugumor, deux cents kilomètres plus
bas sur le fleuve, qui illustrent le déchaînement
de l’agressivité masculine.
Margaret Mead relie cette différence radicale
de comportement à la manière dont les enfants
sont traités. Chez les Arapesh, l’enfant,
fille ou garçon, est soigné par les deux
parents, toujours porté près du corps. Les
pleurs sont considérés d’après elle,
avec beaucoup de sérieux et de gravité.
De manière générale, une attention constante
est portée au bien-être de l’enfant. Chez
les Mundugumor en revanche, les bébés sont
gardés dans des paniers assez grossiers,
loin de la chaleur corporelle des parents,
l’allaitement est vite expédié et les
enfants sont mis en compétition dès le plus
jeune âge. Hommes et femmes se montrent alors
agressifs à l’âge adulte.
Les Chambuli, la troisième société qu’elle
étudie lors de ce voyage, constituent dans
ce modèle un type intermédiaire. Les hommes
y sont rudes et agressifs, mais les femmes
y montrent beaucoup de calme et de douceur.
C’est en fait un exemple parfait de différenciation
sexuelle, l’éducation différente des filles
et des garçons conduisant à ce contraste
à l’âge adulte.
Pour Margaret Mead, ce sont donc ces expériences
de la petite enfance, marquant profondément
le caractère, qui donneraient à la société
toute entière son inclination pour la douceur
ou la violence. En somme, « dites-moi comment
vous traitez vos enfants, je vous dirai qui
vous êtes ». Il faut avouer que la théorie
est assez belle. Un peu trop peut-être, mais
je reviendrai tout à l’heure sur les critiques
qu’on peut lui faire.
En 1932, alors qu’elle est chez les Chambuli
avec son deuxième mari Reo Fortune, Margaret
Mead rencontre Gregory Bateson, un anthropologue
anglais. Ils passent tous les trois des centaines
d’heures à discuter sous la moustiquaire
de leur petite maison. Margaret Mead décrit
ce moment comme une apothéose intellectuelle,
Bateson apportant des éléments déterminants
pour ses propres recherches. Mead, par ailleurs
déçue par l’attitude froide et sévère
de son mari sur le terrain, est touchée par
les petites attentions de Gregory Bateson.
Et ce qui doit arriver, arrive bien entendu,
Mead et Bateson tombent amoureux l’un de
l’autre et Mead se sépare de Reo à son
retour aux Etats-Unis.
Avec Gregory Bateson, son troisième et dernier mari,
Margaret Mead entreprend de compléter
sa théorie et aussi sa vie personnelle. Son
troisième mariage découle de son envie de
devenir mère coûte que coûte. L’attitude
cruelle des Mundugumor à l’égard de leur
progéniture, la décide à élever elle-même
un enfant et Bateson sera d’après elle,
un meilleur père que Reo Fortune. Malgré
de nombreuses fausses couches son envie reste
intacte.
A partir de 1936, le couple réalise de nouveaux
terrains à Bali puis à nouveau au bord du
Sépik, chez les Iatmul, le peuple qu’étudiait
Bateson avant de la rencontrer.
Ensemble, ils deviennent parmi les premiers anthropologues
à documenter systématiquement leurs observations par des photographies et des films
Ils ramènent
plus de 25 000 clichés et 70 kilomètres
de pellicule de leurs terrains.
A leur retour aux Etats-Unis, Mead parvient
enfin à garder un enfant. En décembre 1939,
elle donne naissance à sa fille, Mary Catherine.
A partir de ce moment-là, même si elle continue
ses recherches, Mead ne peut plus s’absenter
aussi longtemps et son travail suscite moins
d’intérêt. Bateson lui, poursuit d’autres
objets d’étude, et sans la passion intellectuelle
d’une recherche commune sur le terrain,
le couple finit par se séparer en 1950.
Les dernières décennies de la vie de Margaret
Mead sont consacrées à des engagements plus
politiques. Elle lutte contre la faim dans
le monde ou contre le racisme, réfléchit
à la condition humaine contemporaine. Elle
meurt à New-York en 1978.
Après sa mort, l’œuvre de Margaret Mead continue de diviser. Elle bénéficie d’une
grande popularité auprès du public, alors que ses écrits sont vivement critiqués par ses collègues.
Plusieurs ouvrages ont même été publiés pour tirer au clair les controverses à son sujet.
En 1983, Derek Freeman critique très fermement
la vision des Samoa par Margaret Mead.
Il revient notamment sur les conditions de
son enquête. Il rappelle que Margaret Mead
ne parlait pas la langue locale, qu’elle
résidait à l’écart des autochtones et
qu’elle n’a basé son étude que sur le
témoignage d’une vingtaine de jeunes filles.
Il est sans doute vrai que l’étude de Mead aux Samoa est un peu… légère.
Mais à
y regarder de plus près, on se rend compte
que la démarche de Freeman n’est pas non
plus exempte de tout reproche. Il a certes
passé beaucoup plus de temps aux Samoa que
Mead, mais ses informateurs ne sont pas forcément plus fiables.
Là où elle avait interrogé
des jeunes femmes d’un milieu modeste, lui
privilégie le discours des hommes, plus âgés,
et jouissant d’une position dominante dans la société.
De nombreux anthropologues ont donc accusé
Freeman de vouloir démolir Margaret Mead
à tout prix, sans faire preuve de nuance.
D’autant qu’il s’agissait là du premier
terrain d’une femme de 24 ans, dans les
années 1920, et que les voyages suivants
ont fait la preuve de son sérieux : entre
huit mois et deux ans sur place, apprentissage
méticuleux de la langue locale, documentation
systématique et méthodique, bref, difficile
de la coincer sur la rigueur méthodologique.
S’il paraît excessif d’accuser Margaret
Mead de malhonnêteté intellectuelle, il
est vrai que ses approches souffraient de
plusieurs biais. En cherchant à expliquer
la société américaine à travers le miroir
de sociétés primitives, Mead déformait
sans doute sa vision des peuples qu’elle
étudiait. Représenter les Arapesh et les
Mundugumor comme des archétypes de tempéraments
doux ou agressifs paraît aussi très réducteur,
et d’ailleurs en partie contesté par les
observations de son deuxième mari.
Après la mort de Mead, sa fille, Mary Catherine
Bateson a aussi révélé au grand public
ce que certains savaient déjà de longue
date : sa mère a longtemps entretenu une
relation amoureuse avec sa collègue et amie
Ruth Benedict. Malgré leur quinze ans d’écart,
elles nouent une relation très intense, elles
relisent tous leurs travaux respectifs, s’écrivent
des poèmes, deviennent amantes et vivent
ensemble par intermittence.
Soucieuse de ne pas faire scandale et de ne
pas nuire à leurs carrières universitaires,
Mead n’a jamais révélé cette relation
qui l’a pourtant beaucoup influencée. D’après
son expérience personnelle, Mead a en effet
affirmé que tous les humains sont bisexuels
à l’origine et que leur éducation les
conduit à privilégier un type de sexualité.
Une généralisation qui a elle aussi subi
beaucoup de critiques.
En réalité, une grande partie des reproches
qu’on peut faire à Margaret Mead sont une
conséquence de son envie d’être « utile
». Mead a en fait toujours eu à l’esprit
que ses écrits devaient être utiles au public,
que son propos devait pouvoir passer clairement
et, quitte à choquer, agir concrètement
dans la société. Et le fait est qu’elle
y est parvenue. Les études sur le genre et
l’identité sexuelle se sont multipliées,
cent ans plus tard, sa vision des rapports
entre hommes et femmes reste une inspiration
pour différents mouvements féministes ou
LGBT.
Merci d’avoir regardé cette vidéo, pour
soutenir ce travail direction Tipeee, n'hésitez
pas à cliquer sur la clochette pour être
tenus au courant de la reprise en septembre,
d’ici là je ne vous quitte pas tout à
fait, le standard Passé sauvage c’est sur
Instagram (un programme digne du Club Med
: rando, roller, jardinage, poésie…).
Je vous souhaite un très bon été
on se retrouve en septembre !